تصور اوضح مع الزميل عبد العظيم محمد اليك
الكلمه
عبد السلام
تواصله وبشكل كبير جدا من قبل فرق الانقاذ
للتو قبل لحظات من ان نتحدث معكم وصلت وصل
فريق انقاذ بريطاني لالتحاق بقيه فرق
الانقاذ المتواجده هنا من المانيا ومن
اليابان ومن اذربيجان بالاضافه الى عشرات
من الفرق التركيه المتواجده والعاليات
وفرق الطبيه المتواجده في هذا المكان مشهد
الدمار كبير جدا
واثار الدمار كبيره جدا كما كنا واكدنا في
اكثر من مداخله هذا اليوم والرئيس التركي
وعد بتقديم مساعدات كبيره لزار المنطقه
وعدم تقديم مساعدات كبيره في
النازحين عن هذه المناطق عموما نحن حاولنا
هذا اليوم رصد المشهد بلقطات اوسع وبصوره
اوسع عبر كاميرا الجزيره بالطائره
الدرون صورنا المشهد في هذه المنطقه ومشهد
يبين الدمار الهائل الذي تعرضت له المنطقه
وكذلك يبين على مقربه من هذا المكان
الخيام اللاجئين الذي نصبت في الملعب
الرئيسي في مدينه كهرمان مرش